alors le nouveau patron du parti
socialiste henri emmanuelli n'est pas un
inconnu du grand public ancien président
de l'assemblée nationale il a dit ses
partisans le garant de l'orthodoxie
socialiste guilaine chenu henri
emmanuelli ou comment en dix jours on
passe de la minorité d'un parti à sa
tête à la veille des européennes
il entre dans l'opposition à michel
rocard parce que selon lui il vaut mieux
grenier hors de la majorité que dedans
je pense que la ligne du parti politique
du parti socialiste n'est pas bonne je
pense que le parti socialiste n'a pas
compris revenu dans l'opposition quel
était son rôle sa place et ce qu'il
devait faire
à 49 ans henri emmanuelli devient le
sixième premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste